well in Beijing China
they call it Elite capture and you have
to say it's an absolutely brilliant
strategy rather than go head-to-head
with your Chief rival the United States
trying to match their Dynamic economy
trying to match their Innovation and
their military muscle why not instead
simply buy off their political and
business Elites
why not simply in a sense decapitate
this superpower by changing the decision
making in the United States to the
benefit of Beijing
they call this Elite capture and what
they're basically looking for
is help on the issues that matter the
most to them
and it's pretty easy to find what do
they want they want unfettered access to
our Capital markets they want unfettered
access to our domestic Market to sell
their goods and they want essentially
unfettered access to our technology
if they can get political and Business
Leaders on board with that agenda they
are happy to cut deals with them help to
make them wealthy to accomplish their
goals now they're realistic in this
strategy because they know that to
maintain political and Commercial
viability you cannot as an American
Elite who has been captured
act in a robotic fashion so the phrase
they use is they're looking for big help
with a little bad mouth
in other words they don't mind if Elites
that they have captured criticize them
for human rights or for their treatment
of the uyghurs as long as they are
helping them on the big things that
really matter they are happy to play
ball
well what I would like to do today is
take you essentially on a tour across
the United States Washington D.C Silicon
Valley New York City I.E Wall Street and
finally the college campuses to explain
and name names of those individuals that
have been captured by Beijing and how
they are helping China essentially
moving towards
ultimately defeating the United States
without having to fire a shot now I know
those are very bold words but I think I
can back it up with information and I
think I'm going to be able to convey to
you the gravity of the situation we face
when it comes to Elite capture so let me
begin first of all in Washington DC the
seat of our power I'm going to talk
about people from both political parties
but I'm going to begin with the first
family of the United States and that
would be the bidens now we first broke
the story about the commercial deals
that the bidens had in China back in
2018. since then of course we've had the
hunter Biden laptop come forward and we
now have congressional committees that
are meeting and looking through
documents that they've actually
subpoenaed but let me summarize
essentially what we know as fact meaning
this is not something I'm asserting or
something I'm Dreaming up every single
thing I'm about to convey to you about
the bidens is supported by either
corporate records from China emails or
documents from the laptop or material
provided by the congressional committees
on the Senate side and now the house
side
here's what we essentially know about
the Biden family in 2009 Hunter Biden
set up a business called Rosemont Seneca
Partners it was supposed to operate in
the realm of international finance
Hunter Biden had no background in
finance he had no background in
international business but that did not
deter him because he had a very famous
name while his father was vice president
of the United States Hunter Biden
secured some 31 million dollars
from four Chinese businessmen
and we're going to talk about them in
the middle in in a minute and there is
not any evidence
that Hunter Biden or the Biden family
provided any tangible business service
in exchange for that money
now first of all let's talk about the
individuals that made these deals with
the bidens and enrich the Biden family
in such a way we actually know their
names because they are mentioned in the
laptop and what's very curious and very
troubling about this is that the four
individuals that made these deals for
the Biden family all have one thing in
common
and I'm not just talking about the fact
that they're Chinese
all four of these individuals at the
time they were helping the bidens had
ties to the highest levels of Chinese
intelligence
so you have to ask yourself is that a
coincidence
what do I mean well let me begin first
of all with a gentleman named Che Fang
Che Fang Hunter Biden called him the
super chairman uh in his email exchanges
at what point he said Hunter said I
don't believe in the lottery anymore but
I believe in the super chairman and he
had reason to because chefang is the
individual that ranged for Hunter Biden
to become a part owner and a board
member of a 1.5 billion dollar private
Equity Fund in China called bhr that was
totally funded by the Chinese government
and again he had no experience in any of
this now when Che Fang was arranging
this deal for Hunter Biden what else was
Che Fang doing well chefang was business
partners with the vice minister of State
security in China this is of course the
government agency that is the entire spy
apparatus of China
so think about that for a second at the
same time that Hunter Biden is getting
sort of hooked into this deal the bhr
private Equity deal the man that's
arranging it is business partners with a
vice minister of State security a
gentleman named maggian by the way
maggian's job
was to recruit foreign Nationals to spy
on behalf of China
so that's deal number one let me talk
about two other ones very quickly the
second big deal that the bidens get in
China is arranged by a business named a
businessman named Henry Zhao now the
email exchange here and the subsequent
transfer of of money uh from Zhao to
Hunter Biden essentially was this Hunter
Biden saying hey my family his words my
family would very much like to do a deal
with you Henry zhou's response yes sure
I'd like to do a deal with you and I
want to do this on behalf of your family
so Henry Zhao wires five million dollars
to Hunter Biden now where does he wire
this money from
he actually wires it from a company he
owns in Hong Kong here's the curious and
troubling part that company that wires
the five million dollars to Hunter Biden
from Henry Zhao includes Henry Zhao as a
business partner it also includes the
family
of the former minister of State security
the man in charge of the entire spy
apparatus of China
so that's deal number two
and then we get to deal number three
this is the so-called cefc energy deal
this is the one that Tony bobolinski was
involved in you've probably heard of in
the case of cefc you have a gentleman
named chairman Yi Who provided some six
million dollars to Hunter Biden well
chairman Yi took over cefc from
individuals who were connected to
Chinese Military Intelligence in fact
chairman Yi himself came from a
background of working for entities
connected to Chinese military
intelligence so what do we have going on
here
we have the Biden family getting 31
million dollars on deals that don't
really require anything from them at all
in at least in a business sense we have
31 million dollars flowing all from
businessmen who have links to Chinese
intelligence this is in my mind a
classic example of elite capture
and what you have is a the first family
of the United States beholden I would
even say compromised to the interests of
those Chinese entities that have paid
him these funds it's an enormous problem
and it's manifests itself in the manner
in which Joe Biden's entire posture
towards China has been represented it is
in my mind the actual definition of big
help with a little bad mouth
does Joe Biden talk about human rights
problems does he talk about the Spy
balloon does he talk about Taiwan you
bet
but when it comes to the things that
really matters about China remember
access to our technology access to our
Capital markets access to uh our
commercial markets to sell our Goods Joe
Biden has absolutely done nothing in
that realm that gives Beijing even the
slightest heartburn
now less people on one side of the
political aisle get a little bit too
confident now let's switch to the
Republican side and talk about a senator
named Mitch McConnell
Mitch McConnell is the leader of the
Republicans in the U.S Senate he has
been in the Senate since 1987 he is
married to Elaine Chao who served in
both the George W Bush Administration
and the Trump Administration this to me
is another example of what I would
regard as Elite capture now in the case
of Mitch McConnell it's a little bit
different than the bidens in the fact
that they actually do have a legitimate
business the shipbuilding business
Elaine's House family owns a company
called foremost Maritime and it's a
shipping company
but their fortunes changed dramatically
in 1993 that's the year that Mitch
McConnell and Elaine Chao took a visit
to Beijing China this is only four years
after the Tiananmen Square massacre
Beijing was desperate to have foreign
political leaders come and visit very
few were doing so but Senator McConnell
and his wife visited there they were not
there as a part of a U.S delegation they
were not there as guests of the Chinese
government directly they were there as
guests of the Chinese State shipbuilding
Corporation Cesc which is the biggest
military contractor in China and
basically what happened in 1993 was
c-e-s-cssc said to The McConnell Chow
Family hey you guys have this small
shipping business Maritime we're this
big state-owned Chinese Enterprise how
about this why don't we build all those
new big ships that you want to ship good
around the world in fact why don't we
Finance the construction of those ships
as well in fact we'll do something even
better for you we will provide the
manpower to actually man the ships when
you're shipping Goods around the Asia
Pacific region and to put the cherry on
top we will actually help arrange
contracts with Chinese state-owned
companies that will help your shipping
business grow
they took the deal and from 1993 to the
present day the shipping business has
expanded enormously and Mitch McConnell
himself has been a direct beneficiary of
this his father-in-law James ciao who
runs this company actually about 10
years ago sent him a gift of between 5
and 25 million dollars we don't know the
exact amount because our elected
officials only have to report these
things in ranges
so you see what's going on here both
sides of the aisle commercial ties and
Mitch McConnell very much fits the same
pattern as Joe Biden he does not
challenge them on their technology
policies he's not challenged them on
access to Capital markets yes he will
criticize their military buildup and
their human rights but he's going to
offer big help with a little bad mouth
Beyond those two individuals there's all
kinds of money sloshing around
Washington DC in fact there are 23
former U.S senators and members of
Congress that right now
are lobbying in Washington D.C
not just on behalf of Chinese companies
but on behalf of Chinese companies
involved in the intelligence military
complex
of the Chinese government 23
some of them are pulling in more than a
million dollars a year so Washington D.C
we have a very real problem in my mind
that decision making on China is being
clouded and influenced by these
lucrative commercial deals that are
being offered to our political leaders
who seem all too eager and willing to
take them
now let me fly across the country and go
to Silicon Valley and let's talk about
some of the biggest names in Silicon
Valley and how I believe they've been
captured this one's a little bit
different though than Washington D.C
because on the one hand in Washington DC
the clear motivation is what money
I can get rich by doing these deals with
the Chinese if you're Bill Gates if
you're Elon Musk
you're already worth 100 billion dollars
or more do you really need the Chinese
to get rich no the motivation is is
different the motivation here is ego the
motivation here is pride and it plays
out in a very sort of destructive way so
what do I mean well let's talk briefly
about Bill Gates founder of Microsoft
Microsoft itself as a company has been
actively involved for decades in helping
China's artificial intelligence research
in fact they support two Research
Laboratories in China that are known
that are known to be linked to the
Chinese military in fact some of the
research at those facilities and the
research that's been offered had
contributed to the military capabilities
of the Chinese governments but it goes
further with Bill Gates Bill Gates is
the owner of a power company called
Terra power Terra power is designed to
produce small nuclear reactors not the
big ones that we commonly see in the
United States but smaller ones and Bill
Gates had the genius idea of saying you
know what I think I'm going to develop
these in conjunction
with a Chinese government
and he actually started to do so it was
only when the FBI and the Department of
Justice said wait a minute you can't do
this this is going to help China put
nuclear reactors on ships and on
submarines that Bill Gates had to stop
there are additional ties as well Bill
Gates is part owner of a Chinese company
called byd byd produces Automotive
components but we byd also provides
guidance systems
for Chinese military rockets and
missiles